now you came in originally for three
episodes Italy there was an option for
for a further a further CDs but I always
just kinda thought that's never gonna
happen you know I mean they won't feel
like when you do get that lead goodness
like I did a great dancer in my flat
honestly I was sorta it's such a
brilliant tool to work on and everyone's
lovely it's just like a nice family
what does it be like playing a ghost yes
it's it's funny because people are
always if people haven't seen the show
they say oh what's your character and
say oh I'm a ghost no thank and who's
that and I'm like yeah it's just you
know I'm I don't know what to say on it
yeah it's good to spun what do you
think's been a secret to shows obviously
it's really loved it's got a huge fan
base and talking the writer is just so
skilled and as with the other writers as
well it's just
the group in general that all brilliant
than the old work so hard and and I
think that's kind of the key to to
success did you watch a show before you
got the part
yeah I watched em I watch when I got the
audition I've seen bits and pieces but I
kind of made sure that I caught up and
stuff and as I was watching it and I'm
watching Marissa kinda thought why ever
not
I've seen this before because it's so
well written but yeah if you weren't
doing being human what would you like to
do next or after being human what would
you like to do next I would love to get
into it to film I would love to continue
doing good TV stuff just just anything
that I can really get my teeth into
tonight I mean particularly appeals here
in the film world a particular genre
think I'd love to do that one film that
can a really strong me with shame when I
went 20 she kind of came out the cinema
like oh my god this is so amazing
hazel every species thank you take your
time
you